Mình chỉ thống mới, tổng bị thư đảng lao động châu tiên chủ tịch COVID-19 trong uống cảm gái.
Sẽ cùng với người dân nước này phát triển đất nước thành một nhà nước sau chúng miat hình vượng và từ đẹp hơn.
Theo hăng thông tấn Trung một châu tiên cà xe nữa, ông Kim trong uống đưa ra càng kết trên trong bài phát biểu tại lễ kiện nhiệm tảm nắm thành lập đảng lao động châu tiên.
Giễn ra ở xưa và lập 1 tháng 6.
Tham dự sự kiện có phái đuàn của các đảng phái và các chính phủ nước ngoài trong bài phát biểu của mình.
Ông Kim trong uống nhất là lịch sử hình thành đảng lao động châu tiên và vai trọc lệnh đạo của đảng trong cuộc cách mạng của đất nước.
Ông cho biết đạo lao động châu tiên đã lạc đạo thành công của chính trình đổi xa hội.
Ở như ra đoàn khang lao của đất nước, xây dựng một đất nước châu tiên thực sự của nhân dân,
thế hiện toàn dễ tư tưởng và lý tưởng sau ở chúng hạ.
Đông thời đồng góc đảng kể vào sự nghiệp cũng tế phy đập lập và công liy.
Chức đó tại xưa mà đồng một tháng 6, cũng đã dễ dựng ra chương trình đồng dễn thế giúp và nghệ thuật.
Măng tiên đã đạo động châu tiên 1 năm.
Các bạn chỉ dễ con nhạc và những dựng mỗi trên nền các ca khúc cách mạng đã tải hiện lịch sử hào hôm của đảng đó độ châu tiên.
Cơ dạy tiên thần yêu nước xấu sắc.